my name's Gary Indiana I live in New
York and that's where I am right now
I'm a writer I've written six novels and
I think seven non-fiction books a lot of
plays and what do they make I make
people uncomfortable writers no longer
have that kind of prestige if they had
when I was growing up we live in a
completely visual culture and people not
only don't read they have no memory left
because of computers all their memory
functions have been externalized into
computers so they no longer feel they
need to need to remember anything and
memory is really the thing you really
need to be reader to be an average
reader you have to be able to remember
what you just read presumably